and think about
it the first time this ever happened so
each and every one of you are part of
history and congratulations to you young
men because I know the coaches identifi
the best kids in terms of not only on
the playing the field but who can be an
example for their institution and that's
what it's all about so here you go
Maurice thank you so much appreciate it
first of all I want to thank Demetrius
Johnson give it up please uh for all
he's
done to bring you guys together I think
this is a beautiful thing when I talked
to him it was two months ago he and I
met and we met at the chess club St
Louis how many of you by the way know
about that club in the Central West End
how many of you know about your chess
club wow wow that's amazing did you know
that that club and the work they're
doing has caused St Louis to be be named
by the US Congress as the capital of
Chess in the United States of
America your city is the capital of
Chess in the United States of America
because of that club and all the work
they're doing with the World Chess Hall
of Fame incredible work they're
spreading chess to all the kids 100
Schools bringing coaches uh so you got
to give it up to that club because they
are bringing chess to our neighborhoods
and teaching chess strategy now when DJ
and I met we started talking strategy in
football I'm a big sports fan I'm a
giant fan coming out of New York New
York Giants and I've always seen a
connection between chess and football
because chess is a strategy game and
football is a strategy game as a matter
of fact I was listening to the coaches
get interviewed earlier and they said
what's the one thing they want to teach
their kids this year what is the main
thing and each coach had something to
say the one I really picked up I forget
what coach said the mental game which
was the coach that said the mental game
there you go he said the mental game he
wants his kids to think on the field to
strategize to be smarter than the kid
next to him because the fact is if you
have a little bit more Talent than I do
but I'm smarter than you I'm going to
beat
you Talent Plus strategy and brains
equals success now I coached a team in
New York called the Raging Rooks I was a
chess team out of central Harlem a lot
of people didn't expect black kids from
the hood central Harlem and all the
problems of Harlem to go anywhere and I
took that team and with dedication and
focus and application and determination
we went to the national championships
and we came in first place ahead of all
the other
teams people didn't expect that of us
but they expected it of themselves and
when I look at you guys you young men
I'm so impressed by your demeanor by
your attitude by your
swag and what we going to do is we're
going to add a little Edge to that we're
going to add the strategies of Chess and
the thing that that board game teaches
that game has been around chess has been
around for500 years for a reason and
we're going to unlock some of those
strategies we're going to work with your
coaches we're going to work with you
guys and show you some of the secret
strategies behind chess and how that
integrates with football it integrates
with life in reality so I'm looking
forward to doing that we're going to
give this Alliance The Edge that other
people don't have that other places
won't have and we're going to take it to
the next level so thanks so much for uh
involving me in the program I really
appreciate it and we look forward to
making this bigger and better thank
you thank you
brother I'm telling you what this guy
he's
aort me youts Andes and sisters and
brothers you all need to go out and
support these young people while they're
playing and lift them up when they
everybody can't win the game okay so
that means when they come home and they
didn't win the game so hey you get them
next time but make sure that you keep
them in the hooks because that's what
it's all about so what do you say what
you say let's go check out what's
happening at the press conference for
the soon to be athlete stars of tomorrow
okay
okay hey folks hey man congratulations
man I mean I think each and every one
you should be feeling proud about what
we just did man I mean that's big time
the kids are feeling important I mean
that's what it's all about man we got to
continue
our our growth in this man so what we
going to do we going to just take a few
minutes and talk about it because this
going to be our meeting for the month I
know you guys cuz you guys go thy
supposed to be me but I know you guys
right in grooving in your your your your
deal so I'm not going to bother you this
week about that stuff right but hey man
congratulations I mean it turned out
great coaches you got to be on time
coach yeah you're right we got to start
being on time we got to start doing
stuff on time folks I mean you know what
I'm saying our credibility is important
the kids are looking up toward us to
make sure that we if we asking them to
be on time we got to be on time you know
what I'm saying we got to I know and
inere some of Y practice and all that
good stuff we got to stay on top of our
game yeah each and every one you should
be proud for tonight man because we got
to have a commitment to make sure this
thing work man y'all have set the bar
y'all don't think yall really understand
what y'all just did tonight I really
don't think y'all truly understand what
y'all done you got the co the kids
looking good man they standing up there
they Shir and TI I mean they proud
that's what it's all about man and now
what we got to do you guys got to tell
me how can we do it while he's in town
he's in town till next week I want to be
able to now I know I can do it the PHL
but I want to make sure I can
then uh normany there
Confluence LIF for life and Confluence
all right I know I can call Dr Adams
next week and say we can I can in
integrate and get some people from obap
or one of other schools to come in town
and talk about and talk about how we can
um do this educational piece I'm going
have Mar re to talk to the kids and
staff and everybody about how this whole
dynamic of chess can work in inable
thinking and and being very very
cognitive of the moves you're making in
life how you block I mean he BR this
down to me I'm like I like this do
like I never thought about it like that
the blocking schemes how you set up your
blind
how you move off the I mean it it it was
a h of a parallel how you explained to
me that's pretty good so would you guys
be up to meet Carlin the superintendent
and getting us a day next week where we
can do a field
trip